jumping right on him you know how much i
enjoyed your movie
um did you make any changes since it
played at sundance
you changed the title uh but we didn't
make any changes obviously we had to
change the title of
the screen but other than that no we
didn't uh we we really had a great time
there and i
i loved my absolute highlight of
sundance
was going into salt lake and sort of
seeing it with a really regular audience
that was great because it's sort of i
mean a film festival sort of artificial
place
and you know you got really sort of keen
film buffs and you've got press and all
the rest of it
but going into uh into a regular place
was wonderful and um it was very moving
actually to watch it there so and i
learned a lot from it so
yeah no but we didn't make any changes
yeah what was your feelings
when they said we're going to go from
ironbark to the courier i mean
personally i actually understand the
title
change like it makes more marketing
sense but i'm just curious what were
your take what was your take
you know what when that when i got wind
of the fact that they wanted to change
the title i was
sort of already for a fight i was like
don't you mess with it
and it was more sort of fear of what it
was going to be
because i knew that there were problems
with the title because every time i
spoke to anyone who i knew they said
what's the name of your film again it
just wasn't sort of sticking
um and i also knew that it wasn't really
about the main character
because that is the name the code name
of
koski who's a pretty crucial character
he's not the main character and
actually as soon as they did a lot of
market research descriptions a lot of
research and they came up with something
i was like yeah i get it i get it
because it sort of describes benedict's
character and i think it's quite
interesting although it's a very sort of
generic title it's quite interesting
because it's about someone sort of
who's just carrying stuff uh
he's just this guy carrying stuff and of
course in the end he makes this massive
sort of intervention in history so
um i went with it and then we did screen
the film with the new title at um
at that there was a sort of moment a
covered free moment
where you could sort of travel and we
went to
um zurich film festival and we we
watched it there with the new title and
it helps the film because people sort of
got the story earlier
and i don't think that's just because
they're swiss i think it was the title
listen you've obviously done a lot of
work in the theater and you've made a
few movies
i'm a fan of your movies so what do i
need to do to get you to make more
movies
i wa i listen i love it you kidding
you know what's extraordinary is that
i was terrified of the very first thing
i did which was actually a tv it was a
shakespeare
um and the minister shooting i was like
oh this is
i feel much more at home here in the
theater i've been working with you for
30 years
i can't explain why it's not like i know
how to do it i'm still learning all the
time you know but i
there's something about that sort of
pressure um of shooting and sort of real
focus on the moment
and being opportunistic just taking
what's there you've done
huge amounts of prep but you turn up and
everyone's there and you sort of gotta
be in the moment and make the most of
what is there and i sort of love that so
you don't need to persuade me i love
making movies and i want to make i want
to make more
love to well if i'm not mistaken you
were
attached or maybe you're still attached
to i believe it's called folios
or harry potties yeah yeah yeah yeah
followers i i knew i was going to [ __ ]
that up don't worry
so what i can't believe i did what did
you
uh what's the status of that is that
actually well fun
i don't know if i've been working and
one of the advantages of this crazy
lockdown i've been locked in my house
once
because i've been working on script and
it's really coming together i mean i'm
quite pleased with the script there's a
lot of hoops to jump through
it's a huge project it's got a massive
cost um but um
i'm pleased with where it is creatively
at the moment so
you know who knows i mean we'll see i
mean i'm really hoping you'll come
together
and there's a couple of other things
that i started working on the
development of
this may sound like a contradiction in
terms but uh an intelligent romantic
comedy
set in london which is a beautiful
script written by a fantastic writer
called nick payne he's basically a
playwright but he's written this
brilliant
sort of it's a bit like sort of annie
hall or something like that as sort of
a it's a script about about really smart
people
who can't relate to one another and it's
great it's fabulous so i you know
i'm trying to get stuff off the ground
we'll see we'll see where it all goes
you know
i gotta go but is there any chance
you're gonna take the people you worked
with on the stage
and and have them in the movie uh there
will be
listen i'm trying i'm definitely trying
to involve like the choreographer
the costume designer and i'm sure there
will be some people who are on stage but
there's also an opportunity to sort of
to branch out into sort of american uh
star actors and so on so
you know it'll be a bit of a mix it'll
be a bit of a mix well listen uh
congrats
you know how much i enjoyed your film
and congrats on everything i wish you
nothing but the best
thank you so much steve really nice to
see you again